well Pope Francis will arrive in Ireland
this weekend amid intensifying scrutiny
over the church's handling of sexual
abuse by priests the Pope asked for
prayers as he prepares for the first
papal visit to Ireland in nearly 40
years he will attend an international
Catholic gathering there but the scandal
forced to u.s. Cardinals to cancel their
trips Jonathan Vigliotti is at st.
Mary's Pro Cathedral and Dublin to speak
to a Cardinal who will be at the Pope's
gathering Jonathan good morning good
morning and that Cardinal tells me this
is a pivotal moment for both the Pope
and the church the Pope expected to
arrive here Saturday morning one of his
first stops will be here at the pro'
Cathedral where he will kneel down and
pray before a candle that has been lit
since 2011 in honor of the victims
there's a dysfunction in the family and
we have to address it this is a really
dark time a darkness within the darkness
Cardinal blaze su Page and sister Liz
Murphy hope Pope Francis can chart a way
forward following last week's
Pennsylvania grand jury report which su
pitch the Archbishop of Chicago calls a
catalogue of Horrors one section
describes a group of priests who marked
their victims with crucifixes to
identify the ones that were easier
targets are you worried that something
like this could surface where you are if
such a ring existed we have the measures
by which we could detect it su pitch
says a series of reforms adopted by
bishops in 2002 have dramatically
reduced abuse cases in the US whenever
there is a violation we name it we come
out with it we tell people what's going
on and and we we make sure that people
are held accountable I think there's
much more needed than just naming
individuals with respect Cardinal
sister Liz Murphy leads one of the
largest religious organizations in
Ireland a country also reeling from the
sex abuse crisis she believes the
Catholic Church's problems are
institutional
it is a very nail
masculine institutional top-down
dictatorial body who wouldn't want as a
woman to see that collapse one church
official now in the crosshairs is
Cardinal Donald Wuerl whom the grand
jury accused of shielding 30 to
predatory priests when he was Bishop of
Pittsburgh there are calls for him to
step down do you think he should he's a
man of good conscience and so I will
leave that to him what do you say to
those people who say let's restructure
starting with every bishop in reality
it'll create anarchy many bishops in the
United States are just as outraged as
the people are by what we read in the
grand jury report in Pennsylvania we
know that the Pope will be meeting with
abuse victims here
what would you encourage him to do
whether it's here in Ireland or
someplace else he does have to give some
specific steps I am confident that he
does have these steps in mind how does
the Pope survive this pivotal moment
this is a virus and this is not going to
be healed over this these coming days to
expect the Pope to come up with a
strategic plan for the Catholic Church
over a weekend in Dublin is quite deaf
to be honest but many critics say that
words are no longer enough they are
demanding action at this point it's
unclear how many victims the Pope will
meet with and whether or not he will
publicly address these allegations while
he's here Nora Waring Jonathan Vigliotti
and Dublin thank you can me sister Liz
Murphy can we learn more from her I want
to be the spokesperson for the churches
yeah right now instituting the forum
she's terrific
I'm praying for sister Elizabeth what
can you do